like I said now I hope you're not taking
for granted last time at the beginning I
said inequality crews are routinely nude
as the hottest kind of induction proof
and that's because the logic is
different it's not like the equations
where everything is like exactly equal
it's like it's not quite what I want so
that's the first thing that's
challenging it's question the second
thing this challenging is what on earth
is this guy doing here right we're used
to induction questions where there's one
variable and that variable is which
which is dominated up to which value of
n but here they decide to do you a favor
and throw in a second variable okay now
that's a bit weird
that's a bit weird to be honest when I
first looked at this question I just
kind of raised my eyebrow at it and I
was like do you even know what to do
with that and even as I progressed
through it didn't become obvious until a
few steps in although that's why this is
important okay so what I'm going to
suggest is we think about the structure
of mathematical induction how it works
and let's just kind of try to step
through this without without you know
worrying about the difference in this
space yet and then see how far we could
get okay so we know that that it's the
same three steps in every ducts reproof
namely tests assume crude okay so let's
just begin their number one test for the
first allowable value right now people
will often look and say hey wait there's
two variables so which is the one that's
changing now when you have a look I
think you can sort of logic out I think
it has to be end that's going forward
and forward and forward because it's the
one that remains in integer land right
which is what induction is really
dealing with okay like I said they ever
equals what is the most common place to
start so by looking at this particular
boundary I'm like oh I think this is the
one that's marching forward and I don't
actually don't think I've ever seen your
approval
and is not the thing that's progressing
one by one by one so I'm gonna test for
N equals one not alpha equals y kind of
test it after equals maybe different
anyway because I can't be good some of
it let's have a go at this as is my
custom for inequality I'm gonna start
with the right hand side the right hand
side is 1 plus 1 alpha grad breaking
okay then I look at my left hand side
again because I'm try to show this don't
pull any like working out of this I'm
literally gonna write 1 plus alpha to
the power of 1 up showing that I can do
the substitution that's 1 plus alpha
which is sure enough greater than or
equal to my right hand side which I
worked up before so I'm gonna live
inside people I've done my base case
happy times now we're gonna make my
assumption which again is going to work
exactly the same way as for any other
induction proof entered with this we
don't like and then somebody's humid
it's true but anyways camp looks like
this and now here come the here comes
the actual work so now is the proof step
so I'm going to prove for the next value
I want what does this look like well
instead of all of the ends up here of
which there are two I'll just replace
that week a plus one so I'm going to
give this
here's my white way or here's what I'm
going after okay now you've seen before
we've got lots of different paths
through for solving an inequality
question in this case I think probably
the easiest way is to just would this
guy make him our starting point and then
see if I can manipulate it with a
sergeant to get into this position okay
so I'm going to begin there so by
assumption I'm just going to state that
and then I think to myself okay what
must be done to this statement to try
and get it close to this statement what
is the difference between these two
things okay so if I just have a look at
both my ten signs right see how there's
an extra 1 plus alpha being multiplied
on the left head time do you notice that
like that that k plus one that one
really means 1 plus alpha times that
whole thing okay so what I'd like to do
is multiply both sides by 1 plus alpha
but hold on you have to be careful
because alpha is it just a constant like
we're used to constants appearing inside
here but alpha is not constant alpha is
a variable this is the thing which sort
of weird salary but it's okay because
the thing i want to x is 1 plus alpha 1
alpha so if i had a look at this and I
say well what is 1 plus alpha if I add 1
to both sides he gives me that so that
means that what plus alpha is a positive
number and that's okay I can multiply
both sides of this inequality by a
positive number even if the positive
numbers changing multiplication by
variables is usually dicey because
you're like what is your variable
positive or negative I don't know which
way the inequality is going to face but
because if there I can't multiply by 1
for self okay so let's go ahead and do
that 1 plus I'm gonna get K plus 1 by
the way what we just said here since 1
plus alpha is positive this is exactly
the same logic that we apply when you
try to solve an inequality that involves
like a hyperbola so if you if you see
something like this okay
you guys know what are the classic
strategy strategies for this is I
multiply both sides by in this case X
plus 1 or scared which gives me this
they are terrified okay now if it's a
little squid the reason I can do this
even though X is variable is because X
plus one as if you square it is
definitely going to be positive so
that's why it doesn't break it doesn't
violate any rules doesn't introduce any
cases or anything like that okay so does
that make sense it looks weird that this
is here in color but the reason it's
there is precisely so I could do this I
have my left hand side exactly the way I
want it so I don't need to buckle down a
few oh now I just have to look at this
right inside and this is what I'm trying
to get forward yeah let's just expand
I've got 1 plus K alpha that's my first
and then I've got alpha plus K alpha
squared
yeah so when I look at this and compare
it to the result I'm getting at let's
write the left hand side it's like oh
look look there's a 1 already there
thumbs up
what's this this is if I take out a
factor of alpha this is k plus 1 alpha
sweet so I've got the thing I want in it
and then I've got an extra bit now you
can't you still don't have the woods yet
right because but K and alpha are
variables so I can't just say oh that's
gonna be positive I'm not guaranteed
that that's positive until I know some
things about these things right so
another one what type of no but must fit
naughty
what type of number is Kate
K is greater than or equal to one right
so in other words the important thing I
want about it is that it's positive okay
so this part is not going to make this
whole thing a negative and then you
would give this guy 4 squared and for us
the important thing is it's a real
number right if we were not a real no
way you could square and get a negative
but thankfully it's not the area we're
in by the way this is the entire wording
of the whole question for the extension
to students how do you know that
alphas are a little we have a look at it
in equality right the real numbers and
this is now sort of going outside
because in for extension to students
real numbers all we call ordered numbers
you can put real numbers either order
right so here's a number line right and
you could say alright here's zero you
give me any other number you like and I
can tell you whether it's before or
after zero like you might say oh okay
how about one then give me another
number
no seriously give you another food okay
so you know how about like how about
like oh hi or how about root 2 all the
real numbers I can place on here and I
could say I can place them in order I
can arrange it in high order but if you
go outside this set right so if I said
okay how about 1 plus PI + 2 minus 3 is
something like that and I said to you
okay which was first can you put them in
high order you like would you like it
you cut there's not like a single
quarter down comparing these right it's
like yeah look this guy this is like
well this is this is higher but this is
further away so which one do you say is
further along so just by making
inequality like this right complex
numbers don't fit in this world so
anyway that's just if you're an
extension wants to I don't know any
other kinds of
that's a logic idea right let's just
remember but but K is greater than one
what about alpha squid because that's
the other piece of alpha square is
greater than one isn't it yeah because
you think about it like think about what
numbers you could put in there you can't
even put in negative one right but you
can put in a static that is zebra
because I can have like um I could have
like alphas off- aha
oh yeah I can't equal 0 because African
easier but the important thing about
that is that it's not making this thing
smaller it's going to make it bigger
even if it's just a little bit okay so
therefore here's the way we're gonna
write this next month one must have the
lovely thing about this as I've just
established is that this is greater than
or equal to like it's it's bigger again
what I actually want right this is like
saying ten plus five is bigger than ten
right it's the same thing here plus an
extra bit okay so if a is bigger than B
is bigger than C then a would be given C
right so this is it to be a guy who I
can just take out there so therefore 100
plus alpha to the K + 1 is bigger than
the actual theorem of time yes
sorry we reach what what does it I will
say like there are TPS for B it's not
for them it's not for them I get to
remind me hey this thing this statement
is different from the others that I'm
making it's not something I actually
know yet as opposed to every other thing
on the board which I'm treating is true
but that thing I've not yet which is why
I'll prove it okay are you happy with
that so whenever you see I told you guys
a chicken's gone before the tundra
Chekhov's gun okay there you go so
checkup was a Russian here's a Russian
playwright and he said his his his
famous a was among anything if there is
a gun hanging on the wall in the first
act of your play it must fire by the
third act right like you don't put
something there just or you didn't put
something it just for the lawls right
it's there for a purpose now if there's
an inequality there it is some kind of
restriction and it's all the war the
first act it has to fire huh
by the third day right you you have to
invoke it somewhere and if you haven't
you know an easy thing to do would just
be to say oh I have to get this to be
this so use multiply through right cuz
that's that's what I have to do but if
you don't invert that restriction you
can't do that because you don't go
between that inequality guys and that's
an easy way to I mean you know how we
were talking about awareness that we
didn't like three months ago but there
are five things to put why don't you say
what about you right there right on in
working